The Marvel Cinematic Universe grows just a
little bit bigger and usually a whole lot
weirder with every new movie and TV show that
slides in front of our eyeballs.
When the original Iron Man came out back in
2008, the world he lived in seemed pretty
grounded in reality.
The strangest thing that could possibly happen
in that film was a rich guy deciding to build
himself a suit of armor in a cave to become
an international vigilante.
Then fight another rich guy in some other
armor who wanted to be an even worse international
vigilante.
That's pretty strange, but not out of the
realm of possibility, right?
We're still waiting for Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg to throw down and televise the
whole thing on Facebook Live.
But since then, we've seen gods, monsters,
whole other planets, whole other dimensions,
and all sorts of magical hijinks unfold in
ways that would make any sane person's head
spin.
So how has the MCU kept feeling as real and
fun as ever?
Well, former Marvel Studios head of visual
development Charlie Wen has some ideas on
that.
The man in charge of just about all of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe's designs over the
past decade sat for an exclusive interview
with us to talk about how and why Iron Man
was actually the perfect superhero to kickstart
the MCU as we know it.
"What was good with Iron Man is that it laid
a foundation for what is tech on Earth.
How do we ground it to Earth and to things
we understand?
Tech is something easier for us to sort of,
we use it every day, right?"
He explained that Iron Man's connection with
technology is a convenient starting point
for audiences to find a connection with a
world that looks a lot like our own, but is
also full of super-people.
That helpful foundation revealed that, despite
Iron Man's then-reputation as a lower-tier
comic book character, he was the perfect choice
to kick off Marvel Studios' cinematic ambitions.
"Most people would have thought like, 'Why
are you choosing a character that is sort
of just kind of a B character in the Marvel
comics world?'
But you know I think that was kinda a smart
move."
But technology isn't the only reason Iron
Man was such a strong choice for Marvel's
first film in a shared cinematic universe.
Even though we all use phones and computers
every day, very few moviegoers are also jet-setting
billionaires.
That's why Iron Man's alter ego Tony Stark
and the fact that Robert Downey, Jr. played
him was that other crucial piece of the puzzle
to help audiences connect with the film, as
well as the world it shows on-screen.
"It was great getting Iron Man situated and
then having Robert Downey in that role was
amazing.
I mean, he kind of is that character.
it's all the flaws
that he sort of just puts out there, right?"
"How do you make that character and that world
more relatable and less scary?
It's not a Superman character, where it feels
maybe too perfect and too alienating and hard
for people to resonate with.
It's somebody with lots of flaws.
Not all of us have the same kind of flaws
that Iron Man did, or Tony Stark, but I think
it's so obvious that it makes it safe for
anybody to approach."
Once Iron Man established the baseline of
the MCU's reality, the studio could start
to explore bigger, weirder ideas.
The next logical step, of course, was to try
to get as weird as possible, as quickly as
possible.
Marvel Studios' third movie was 2011's Thor
which happened to be the first film Charlie
Wen worked on at the company as the head of
design.
"When you're trying to write some kind of
story, paint an image, one of the things that
you do first is you figure out what your limits
are.
The farthest you're gonna go, where are you
gonna start with, and so it's your contrast.
What is your contrast?"
That philosophy determining the contrast was
an approach Wen used while designing all of
the MCU movies he worked on, like Guardians
of the Galaxy characters Gamora and Drax the
Destroyer.
As it turns out, Marvel Studios itself wound
up doing just that by releasing Iron Man and
Thor so close to each other, since they're
literally worlds apart.
"That was the big thing about laying out Iron
Man and Thor.
It was one of the biggest contrasts that we
could find, and could this still work?
'Cause if this can work, there's a lot of
play in the middle."
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos with
Charlie Wen about the creation of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.